es ist ein riesiger riss und er ist der
vorbote eines unglaublichen geologischen
ereignisses der kilometer langes ist 15
meter tief 20 meter breit und hat
bereits häuser und straßen zerstört er
ist der erste vorbote der abspaltung des
ostafrikanischen kontinents der entsteht
dort gerade enden wird der riss in einem
neuen mehr dass sich zwischen rest
afrika und aus afrika schien wird was
jetzt passiert und was das wäre dann
kenia bedeutet jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
vielen dank erstmal für den
themenvorschlag auf whatsapp mehrere
leute aus der community hatten das thema
entdeckt und mir gemeldet wir auch dort
teil meiner redaktion werden könnt
erfahrt am ende des videos
dieser riss ist erst der anfang er war
die folge von starken regenfällen und
brachte zum ersten mal das
auseinanderbrechen das abbrechen einer
neuen kontinentalplatte an die
erdoberfläche plötzlich ging nichts mehr
auf der maybachstraße in kenia die
vielbefahrene straße wurde durch den
riss unterbrochen und musste erst wieder
aufwendig repariert werden häuser wurden
zerstört und was jetzt immer klarer wird
das ist erst der anfang dieser riss wird
sich durch ganz kenia ziehen und das
land langsam teilen am anfang wird es
nur eine schlucht sein die sich aber
immer weiter auf teilt bis meerwasser
einströmen wird und das land irgendwann
auf zwei kontinenten liegen wird grund
ist der ostafrikanischen graben verläuft
vom horn von afrika bis nach mosambik im
süden tausende kilometer lang und
entlang driften die westliche nubische
platte und die östliche somalische
platte aus anderen da jedes jahr um 200
zentimeter alle 40 jahre sind es einen
meter in 400 jahren also zehn meter und
in 4000 jahren 100 meter es wird also
noch etwas dauern bis sich die platten
trennen aber es wird immer besser zu
sehen sein
in der geologie wird damit gerechnet
dass es 20 bis 60 millionen jahre dauert
bis hier wirklich ein neuer kontinent
entstanden ist allerdings ist der riss
dem mann jetzt in kenia sieht nicht
direkt genau die stelle an der die
kontinentalplatten auseinanderbrechen
vielmehr entstehen durch das
auseinanderdriften hohlräume und ihm die
werden bei regen sand und erde von der
oberfläche gespült oben rutscht die erde
danach und es tun sich immer mehr risse
auf und wahrscheinlich wird das entlang
des ostafrikanischen grabens immer mehr
passen werden zerstört häuser und
wahrscheinlich werden durch diese
tektonischen bewegungen auch neue
vulkane entstehen
geologisch wird es also sehr spannend in
afrika in zeiträumen von vielen
millionen jahren
wenn er als erstes neues zu neuen
kontinenten und geologie und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet
hier meine telefonnummer whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion freundlich so mitmachen und
mir eben themen vorschlagen oder an
abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen
was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken achter kontinent
entdeckt expedition unterwegs ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran